In reality, this term "sexual jihad" is
very rare. My uncle asked
me how it happened, and I told him, "Well, that's how it happened." My husband just
stared blankly, didn't say anything, neither yes nor no.
After a while, I went down to Abu
Diab's, greeted him, and sat with him. He
told me Sheikh Iyad wanted to come in. I
told him, "
Not today, tomorrow." I went in, and she came the next day, so I left the same day. She came the
following day, and I said, "Okay." He came in again, and Sheikh
Iyad wrote the marriage contract with me. They did the same thing: they wrote the contract,
put a cloth over his hand, he prayed two
rak'ahs, married me, and then divorced
me. Sheikh Iyad finished and left. I grabbed myself and left the
place. But while I was there, I saw
many girls and women. I went to Abu Diab and said, "
Abu Diab, what's going on? There are so many girls and women here. I
told him, 'You might be laughing at me. You have girls and women; maybe you're having relations
with them or marrying them.'" He said, "No, you're
crazy. I don't have them. They're for the men because, of course, they don't
have them."  The women here are here now, and their women are far away from
me in Kafr. I told him, "Yes,
okay, but I don't mean the idea." I was a
little confused. I told him, "I don't know, come sit down for a
bit." I was confused. I told him, "
Abu Diab, I don't know what to say to you." I told him, "
These girls you have, how do you deal with them?" He
told
me, "A mufti issued a fatwa. They're not sheikhs, they issue fatwas as they please and give as they please.
Fahd is a hypocrite.
I mean, the mufti, Sheikh Iyad
Awshan Abu Nazeer, who issued the fatwa that it's permissible to sleep with them and have anal sex with them." I
told him, "But it's strange,
these girls." He told me, "Your understanding is
enough." I told
him, "And the women?" He told me, "For several people now, but the
sheikh who issued this fatwa sends women
and exposes his honor. Why didn't he send them? Why doesn't he come and
fight with them himself, since he accepts this for his
honor? Take away from religion and from any religion, whether it's
Islam or Christianity or anything else, with all due respect to all
religions."  What religion would condone this? First of all,
morality is more important than anything else. Where are
the ethics in this matter? Where is the honor? Where is the reputation? I became so nervous.
I told him I
wanted to go home. I went to my
house. Of course, I left
Sabina. I rented a house and stayed there, and I started going back and forth.
During the examination of this
patient, we noticed that she mentioned that her intercourse was
normal. Her intercourse was
abnormal. She had engaged in anal sex.
We noticed during the examination of
the bed that the woman had some reactions
on her body. In the genital area, we noticed the
same thing: profuse,
frothy vaginal discharge. During the vaginal examination, we noticed that the
vaginal roots were severely congested, along with the cervix.
This is evidence of the issue of
repeated intercourse and the apparent genital intercourse she
had. The ultrasound examination was within the
normal range for the pelvis. We
examined her anal sphincter and noticed a
clear case of retraction. This is evidence that she had engaged in
intercourse more than once.  Through
anal intercourse, fatwas for which God has sent down no authority are used to deceive
people to satisfy their desires and
instincts. These takfiri extremists
used everything at their disposal in their war
on Syria. After legalizing and permitting what is forbidden for themselves, they
stopped at no limits in using
fatwas issued by sheikhs of sedition and
misguidance. A new phenomenon in Syria is "sexual jihad,"
the recruitment of girls from inside and outside Syria, carried out with
meticulous coordination by these
obscurantists.
One example of a "sexual jihad" is Sara al-Alam, who received
special lessons from al-Qaeda sheikhs before the events
in Syria. She was exploited after the war and the formation of
Jabhat al-Nusra. She began by joining al-Qaeda
in the tenth grade. She attended religious lessons at the
Imam Mosque in the city of al-
Bukamal. The mosque was near the al-Hajjanah area, and there was a
sheikh there named Abu Muhammad who used to
come from Iraq to give them religious lessons. The al-
Qaeda ideology dictates that anyone not
affiliated with al-Qaeda is considered an infidel.
The problem now is that they are promoting this idea, and there are
those who listen to them in the absence of any legitimate religious authority.  A
clear religious foundation, because we had a problem:
everyone was issuing fatwas as they pleased. At first, we
girls took religious lessons, mostly for
girls. Then, as
the groups grew, they became larger. The main topic was "
sexual jihad," since we girls believed that
anyone affiliated with al-Qaeda could engage in it.
We presented this idea and justified it with
Quranic verses that were distorted and hadiths attributed to the Prophet (peace be upon him),
but which turned out to be distorted. We believed it was
permissible for us, as girls affiliated with al-
Qaeda, to engage in sexual relations
with anyone from Jabhat al-Nusra or al-
Qaeda in general. They told us it was
obligatory. We girls
affiliated with al-Qaeda. Later, after I
finished my religious lessons and the events in
Syria began, I started recruiting girls. I gave them
religious lessons to explain the ideas to them
in detail and tried to
monitor their behavior.  I was explaining to them matters of
prayer, things like how to enter the mosque without having performed ablution.
I worked with them in the field, transporting
weapons, recruiting girls, giving religious lessons. The
battalion was
formed with girls and boys. I recruited the girls
after the battalion was formed in June. The first time
was with Ahmed Najah Al-Issa. He asked me to engage in sexual intercourse with someone affiliated with Jabhat al-Nusra.
We had this
belief, an obligation to engage in sexual intercourse with anyone affiliated with
Jabhat al-Nusra. Later, after engaging in sexual intercourse
with his brother, I engaged in sexual intercourse with his brother, Ammar Al-Issa.
I engaged in sexual intercourse with people outside of Syria. There were two people from
Libya, one from Tunisia, one from Morocco, one from
Egypt, and in Damascus, there was a Turkish person, a
French person, a Saudi prince, and a
Qatari person. We were almost... I mean, more than that. Anyone who engaged in sexual intercourse, we would take money
from him, sometimes $300,
sometimes $400. If he wasn't a jihadist and carrying
weapons affiliated with Jabhat al-Nusra, we wouldn't engage in sexual intercourse
with him or if he wasn't a financier.  Before Jabhat al-Nusra, they would
film the operation with us. They would try to tell
them, because as soon as I talked about us in front of
anyone, they would say, "It's tempting to publish
videos and clips." They would record everything on
video clips, some with digital cameras, some with
mobile phones. They would even
film things, even the details of the
work of everyone I worked with. They would record
videos on their phones and
laptops. I worked with the Sahwa Brigade in Damascus.
I told you, I transported ammunition. I worked in the field hospital. I
transported messages from the Walkman there. I transported
car bombs. You always find people ready to
receive without thinking, without using their minds. The
marriage groups were always around. Any sheikh or
battalion would talk about the issue to overthrow the Syrian state. A
new fatwa permits "sexual jihad." Jabhat al-Nusra after "sexual jihad." Say "Allahu Akbar"
three times and she becomes yours. A
former dancer supervises the girls who are "
sexual jihadists." Or is it more tiring?  Female jihadists participating in "
sexual jihad," followed by Umm al-Baraa, a 13-
year-old Tunisian. Gulf sheikhs exploit the bodies of Syrian women in
camps, and
a girl recounts her experience with "sexual jihad." From "sexual
jihad" to "incest jihad," the new
jihadists in Syria. The new jihad permits
brothers in the Ahrar al-Sham organization, affiliated with Jabhat al-Nusra, to
marry each other under the
guise of jihad due to the scarcity of girls
among the jihadists in this organization. Hello, in Jabal al-
Zawiya, we have a region in Jabal al-Zawiya with more than a
few villages. There's a sheikh there,
Sheikh Hussein, who brings, for example, a brother and sister together, and he makes them live together,
not that they are
permissible for each other, so that they can get married. Of course, they are affiliated with
Jabhat al-Nusra. Anything from Jabhat al-Nusra, whether in Aleppo, Jabal al-Krad, the villages of Idlib, the
heart of Idlib, Raqqa, or Hasakah, in all
the areas they control, they are there. I
mean, what was in a car, what was on a motorcycle, what
was in a cup, whatever.  He would put his hand on her head and say "Allahu Akbar"
three times. She would then become his wife. She was a woman, and he was a man, whatever he was. I
mean, even in the case of Jannin, we lose the
Jannudi from his loss to the Quran. I mean, there are more than one case like this.
This is something I saw with my own eyes.
I mean, a beautiful woman and a
group of them would gather around her, for example, any beautiful woman. They would lie down on her head, put their hands on her head, and say "Allahu Akbar." The Liwa al-
Tawhid group, in front of the
Kasn, which is affiliated with Jabhat al-Nusra, had a story
about a sheikh who was
killed. They killed a Chechen man who had gone to the sheikh's
wife, put his hand on his head, and said "Allahu Akbar." A sheikh from Kasn went to his wife and found a Chechen man sleeping with her. He put his hand
on his head and said "Allahu Akbar." The sheikh
saw his wife sleeping with a Chechen man. The sheikh left him and asked him, "
What's this?" The man replied, "She became my wife. I said 'Allahu Akbar.'" The
sheikh left her and went to the
Chechen man's wife.  He put his hand on her head and said the
takbir three times while the sheikh was asleep next to his wife.
The Chechen man woke up and asked him what he was doing. The sheikh replied, "You said the takbir over my wife, and I said it
over yours." The sheikh said, "
You can't say the takbir over my wife. I'm only saying it
over yours." The sheikh asked, "Why, Sheikh?" The sheikh
from the Kastan said, "Why? Is your God different from
mine?" So they slaughtered an animal for the sheikh. I saw
this, and I mean, I don't know, I was very scared. I was
afraid they would say the takbir over me because they would say it over my
wife, and then it would be permissible for him. I
know a story from Aleppo. One of the girls I talk
to, I'm from Aleppo, and she and her mother weren't in the
street. A Chechen man, a Libyan or a
foreigner, lay down on her and wanted to say the takbir over her.
Before he could say it, she said it over him. She said, "God is great, God is great!
My daughter, your sister, is here!" He wanted to go after her, but then she said, "I'm not going to let him have sex with her."
Of course, it took an hour or two.  It's permissible for me for the rest of my
life. When I
went, I said, "This is not true jihad, it's all
forbidden." I said, "This is revenge against my husband, Khaled. I
want to get revenge on him." I said, "This is personal pleasure for me.
Since he married another woman, I want to get revenge." I saw him with my own eyes. I
liked his sweet tongue.
[Music] He was so gentle,
you could feel his romantic nature. His movements were sweet, seductive. That's why
I liked him. They used to tell
us things.
We're religious, you know. Even if a man talks, if a man
says that his wife is older than him in front of him, or
if he wants to talk about it, he'll also bring him into it. Sodomy, you know,
sodomy with boys. They don't
have any problem with that. I'm not married, I can't
get married again. He told me, "No, you can get married. This is
jihad in the path of God." I told him, "But I don't know, does it make sense to me?" He said, "No, this is happening. My son, this is jihad in the
path of God." And he wrote a proper marriage contract. I don't know how he
played with
my mind. He told me that this is jihad in the path of God.  And it's
not wrong if you
get married again, meaning this way he took me, what did he enjoy? He messed with my head
so much I couldn't understand
anything anymore. If she's seven years old, he doesn't have a
problem, seven years old, he doesn't have a problem. The important thing is that
they rape her, that they sleep with her, that they race each other over her
until he grows up over her, shouting "
Allahu Akbar" three times, then she becomes his wife for an hour or
two. This is all a lie, and it's all forbidden, forbidden, a lie, a
lie, and nobody is behind it.